if you're looking to learn a new skill
in 2023 you should look no further than
Autodesk for example this image right
here was created in under 20 minutes
using Autodesk Revit if you want to
follow along and learn how to recreate
this exact thing using Autodesk Revit
you can find the video on YouTube right
now 100 for free if you're still
thinking why Autodesk well Autodesk is a
global leader in 3D design engineering
and entertainment software so that means
Autodesk is forever innovating forever
improving their products and always at
the top of their game for me using
Autodesk today was about understanding
what my engineer is using what my
Consultants are using and genuinely
having a better understanding of what
the rest of the industry is using every
single day if you want to see the full
video and all things architecture
related make sure you hit that subscribe
button